[Music]
[Applause]
nick wright joins us co-host fox first
things first
i know what are you talking about dan
just talking about my jumper
no and i know it's your favorite topic
but
at some point
you know reality's got to set in
i mean jim paxton hit a jumper to win a
championship no and you no no no no no
no no no no oh john paxson yeah i
thought you're talking about john paxton
okay all right jim paxton you know what
is out of my purview okay i think the
caller
was was would be more interested in john
paxton to be totally honest with you jim
paxton hey okay you know what i i
started off on a bad foot i thought you
were talking about john paxton i
realized as i said it saw a little
twinkle in your eye you're like oh i got
nick in the jackpot yeah okay yeah my
bad yeah my bad because you're an nba
historian and i just a historian yeah
that is true okay it's a bad job by me
yeah but you also did just say you like
to be more like clay thompson who might
have the prettiest jump shot in nba
history thank you
no that's not a no oh what do you mean
thank you i was saying clayton
all right now you have that okay if
you're going by just looks of jumpers
just the cosmetics of this
um
you put reggie miller's in last place
sorry go ahead all right ray allen
clay
steph
um
i don't put steph there you don't think
that's a step
i don't think like his
form and release
are as pretty as clay or ray allen and
i'm trying to find other guys i think
steph
is just it's just the best you know it's
just the best jump shot ever but as far
as like when you watch it you're like oh
that is that is picture perfect like ken
griffey jr swing
ray allen and clay are the two guys that
come to mind ahead of everyone else
i think i think steph
has to shoot that way to get his shot
off he does have to take different
angles clay is a catch and shoot ray
became a catch and shoot steph is not a
a catch and shoot player yet but he you
know he might emulate his father later
in his career
well yeah i was going to say dell kind
of had a prettier jumper
than steph and again this is i'm not
listen i'm not draymond green i'm not
taking shots at steph curry you know my
that's not my place right now i i think
it makes it more remarkable what he's
able to do but also because of the
different angles
and the
because of his size he he can't do it as
traditionally as some other guys would
but this isn't what you wanted to talk
to me about so go ahead is everything
okay with you and draymond green that he
called you called john called you nikki
give us a summary of why draymond green
has a problem with you well because
draymond green's true passion is media
criticism not basketball discussion and
draymond like let's let's be very clear
here on what's happening with draymond
green draymond green
finds does not see the obvious hypocrisy
in his opinion
that if you didn't play
in the nba
you shouldn't have a seat at the table
at discussing or criticizing or
critiquing nba players
however
if you have no training whatsoever in
journalism commentary or media you of
course are able to criticize
professionally trained journalist
commentators media and by the way i i
think athletes turned commentators is a
great thing i am not trying to exclude
anyone from the group i i think there's
an obvious hypocrisy in those trying to
exclude others not wanting that same
exclusion to happen to them but the
other thing is this like
draymond is he's running out of content
and so liz we talked about my andrew
wiggins thing he had a lot of my andrew
wiggins stuff wrong they're saying that
i need to you know own up to the opinion
i tweeted out the andrew wiggins take
the moment the warriors beat the mavs
i'm the one that put it back into the
ether but that's fine
but that guy that got him some traction
people were like oh yeah kill nick on
andrew wiggins so he does it right after
they win the championship and then he
goes on a little 10-day break and the
next podcast and it's like oh boy
this time of year the sports commentary
game's a little tough so no no games
going on no sports no stories so let's
just run it back
but then skip was on vacation steven a's
on vacation and all of a sudden it's
like oh boy you know what
what if i run that same nick almost word
for word the same nick wright opinion
but i'll call him nicholas
oh that'll get him
that'll get him
so listen i get it uh new media and so
you know they're coming for all of us
but i just you know i'm excited to see
what the next chapter is
we're talking to nick wright he is a
co-host of first things first you don't
take time off like skip and stephen a
you're you guys are always there
grinding
well no that's i mean no i'm gonna take
time off here and skip stephen and by
the way don't take time off like skip or
stephen a or dan patrick you know what i
mean who i believe is about to go on a
quiet the vacation um no but i'll i'm
gonna take time off just later i'm gonna
take some time off in july and august
and so but not right now right now you
know with nba free agency i need to be
on the air i need to be discussing the
knicks
giving jail in brooks
okay 110 million but i did wonder though
that i wonder what luca thinks about
this
that that it feels like he needs
he can't afford to lose players like
this now
mark cuban can afford maybe that you
know they don't want to spend that money
but if you're luca
are you closer or further away
listen i think that and the maps are
smart i think they go to luca and they
say listen
let me show you what happened with
anthony davis he was great at a young
age
so the team
overreacted
traded a lot of its future for a good
but not great at the time player drew
holiday gave him a defined ceiling
lebron james great at an early age team
then tied you know said mo williams come
on down you we if you're good if you're
so great sometimes what hurts you is
we feel like we have to microwave it and
we get a second player who is not
a true difference maker pay him like he
is and we're locked into the team
we've got you know a 10-year plan for
you and by the way we went out and got
uh christian wood tim hardaway jr is
coming back so we're not going to be
worse but what we're not going to do is
is make it so the our big two is you and
jaylen brunson we want the secondary
player to be better than jalen brunson
is i think luke is smart
and i think he would understand that i
like because or else you get in a bit of
a situation dan the hawks found
themselves in the hawks tricked
themselves a bit by believing that that
conference title run was who they were
and they locked everybody up and then
this year is maybe more realistic who
they were and they're like oh we're not
even close to good
and now what do you got to do you trade
three drafts
unprotected for i and i like deshante
murray a lot i think he will really help
them but now they're all in that's their
team now it's going to be trey desjante
you know what i mean and there are other
pieces like that's going to be for the
bulk of the next five years who the
hawks have they have no flexibility i
like teams that have the flexibility for
if and when dame says i'm sick of this
if and when somebody who's a real
difference maker asks out
better move the lakers didn't get kyrie
or the clippers got john wall
oh i think they'll i wish the lakers had
gotten kyrie kyrie and lebron work
flatly it works so i think i think it's
a bad move that they didn't get kyrie
and
i
am
the john wall thing i'm not against i
think anyone acting like they know
that john the john wall thing is going
to work is being disingenuous but i also
think anyone acting like they know that
he's cooked is being disingenuous i he
was on the shelf last year not for
injury but because the rockets just
wouldn't play him and we saw how horford
that happened with him in okc and then
our that actually did his body good he
was good for the celtics i think
clippers are going to be really good and
i think anything they get out of wall is
a
bonus i was just you know kyrie going
back to the nets i think people are like
yeah let's move on to the next story i'm
like no no this is still a story this is
fluid yeah because if i'm kd
i don't know what i got here and at what
point do the nets know hey he's going to
play play for that next contract are we
going to trade him
it just feels like what do you think's
more likely more likely than not kyrie
finishes the season with the nets
even money bet you can take yes or no
i'd i
i would never i would never bet
on him
[Music]
to do what is logical like when he said
oh you know whatever
great people are different people and
you know we change the world and then he
opts in like he didn't do anything
daring like dude that was the greatest
tweet they're like those who dare to be
different change the world by daring to
be different i'm doing the most basic
thing imaginable um no listen kyrie's a
different cat
obviously but i i don't i agree with you
the story's not over i think there are a
lot of interesting pieces of it one that
the nets offered him longer term
contract he didn't take
two that the shams reported well not
shams reported he told shams he was
opting in not telling the nets three
wendy reported
that joe's that shawn mark said the okay
from josiah even if it meant losing
durant
rather than give kyrie the max all of
those things lead me to believe
that kyrie is on his last strike and now
that he opted in he has no leverage they
send him anywhere so i think that he's
got to be on his you know best behavior
and that includes no sabbaticals no paid
time off like
i don't know he's not a reliable guy
i'm guessing that he'll be traded i
don't think he ends the season unless
they're playing so well
and there is chemistry
and that
it feels like they're just waiting for
kd to give the sign like you know what
go ahead because katie's been there for
four years it doesn't feel like they're
going to ship kd after if they you know
trade kyrie
no and katie's excellent i mean and
katie doesn't want to leave and the
other thing is this check the nets
roster something will jump out to you
they don't have any forwards
but durant they they have a few centers
a bunch of guards and durant is the only
guy on the roster listed as as a forward
small or power the reason i mentioned
that is this
they
even if kyrie were on his best behavior
one could argue
that
trading him for some wing depth you know
durant tweeted during the draft it's a
wings league and i think that was about
the players being drafted but it also
was an interesting comment on his team
that has no wings other than him it's
got small guards and shooters and then
claxed in and you know biggs and so i
think there is an argument to be made
even if kyrie doesn't do anything that
the nets might look at it and say we
have even with ben simmons we have
plenty of shooting what we need is more
wing defenders out there and maybe kyrie
can get us some of those
and i i misspoke yesterday because i
thought you know what ben simmons is
going to be healthy but i don't know
mentally physically he went through back
surgery and is not going to be available
this summer until i i guess training
camp
at the earliest here so
factor that
factor that in he's not going to play in
the summer league he's not going to have
any run nothing's not great which is by
the way did you see the vegas odds on
this the vegas odds on the nets have
been more skewed than any team i can
ever remember seeing they are the
favorites in the east
they have better odds than
than milwaukee does
i don't get that at all i just flatly
don't understand yeah the celtics i mean
why would they have better odds than the
celtics
i i i the public loves them i don't know
it makes no sense to me
uh great to talk to you as always
you too i if it was my internet
connection screwed up here at the end no
you're gonna mess something up for you
no one good oh okay i i was worried
about that okay you enjoy your vacation
i um
i've got something that i'm sending to
you dan
but you're not gonna be there to receive
it and now i find out no one's gonna be
there to sign for it so i got a big
problem that i gotta take care of that i
might need to hit fritzy offline on i
might need i i might need one of your
guys to sign for something what uh so
i'm just letting you give me an idea of
what it is
uh it's a
it's a token of my appreciation of our
friendship
and i you and the crew can share it
that's what i will tell you is it
something that
if we wait a week
then it might spoil
it it's something i would prefer not to
be left out in the sun for a week yeah
it's that is true um and so yeah but i
didn't time this right and you know
shipping delays and you know
infrastructure plans and i don't know
why don't you wait until we're back and
then send it
it's already it's it's in root
is the problem do you want me to give up
my vacation not go on vacation just to
get the gift that you're gonna send me
no but i might want someone to hang out
at your studio tomorrow for a few hours
to sign for a patch all right
but you don't owe me anything you don't
i don't know no no it's a token of my
appreciation of our friendship that's
all okay that's all it is okay how much
is it worth
oh
i don't know uh is it more than my token
of appreciation of our friendship no no
i don't know listen man i didn't wanna i
don't we we didn't talk about that or
not that's up to you no it is not but
it is
it's worth more than i would like to go
to waste
okay it's worth it it's worth enough
that if you wanted at a casino you'd
have to fill out a form
okay
how about that
i i
wanted to make sure that uh i showed my
appreciation for nick so i i bought him
a watch
okay oh okay i didn't know if we could
talk about this on the air no dan
dan bought me a breitling i'm wearing it
right now dan made fun of me i did
wearing a fake watch on television i did
and then
said told my wife he would buy her a
real one even though she owns one in a
very uncomfortable moment
and then talked about it all on the air
yeah and then i felt bad
sent me on father's day a package that
just said who's your daddy and it was a
breitling
it's a true story i know
and now i'm like god doggit now i gotta
get him something you didn't you didn't
no no it was it was so great to just
send that and have you open it up with
no no name attached to it just said
happy father's day who's your dad's your
daddy yeah and then i called him and
said what are you doing and do you know
what he said america
what ballers do that's what he said
you're like 70 years old i know like
what do you why do you talk like this it
was such a such a flex
and so yeah so
i i you know i sent something back have
a good fourth buddy hey uh my best to
the family
oh the kids do yeah the kids do
good all right i'll see you later thank
you
that's nick wright let's take a break
when we come back did you have an i-team
report there paul well people a lot of
people are asking does nick wright have
a ponytail or a man bun going on because
they couldn't tell with his hair
situation it's getting longer but it
looked like it was in some type of bun
oh i don't think he's a bun
i don't want as a journalist i want to
accuse anybody i think it was more
mullet than bun